[Musica]
empatia corrisponde sostanzialmente a
nostro bisogno di comunicazione e di
condivisione
viviamo in un'epoca di crisi economiche
di catastrofi naturali di lacerazione
dei rapporti e delle relazioni sociali
di violenze commesse seguito all'odio e
al fanatismo e quindi il richiamo
dell'empatia ci serve per aiutare gli
altri per occuparci almeno non essere
indifferenti alla miseria e alle
privazioni di vaste popolazione del
nostro pianeta
però per aiutare gli altri
e necessario non considerarli soltanto
delle vittime passive qualche volta noi
pensiamo che abbiano solo bisogno di un
aiuto materiale si tratta invece di
sapere che sono uomini donne che hanno
una storia un progetto di vita dei
desideri ed è proprio qui che dobbiamo
chiederci ma perché per amare gli altri
dobbiamo vederli soffrire già parlato di
indifferenza spesso pur vedendo un altro
che soffre
voltiamo la testa dall'altra parte
ora l'empatia è proprio la capacità che
ci permetta di entrare direttamente in
contatto anche semplicemente guardando
una persona in faccia cioè vedendo per
esempio che ha una smorfia un po cupa
delle labbra oppure agli occhi un
pochino triste con l'empatia ci mette in
contatto diretto con le persone a
partire proprio da gesti non ci vogliono
spesso nemmeno le parole no per capire
che un'altra persona ha qualche problema
anche certamente che ce l'ha con noi per
esempio o ha bisogno di qualcosa d'altro
si tratta di una capacità e questo
bisogna saperlo ripetercelo molto spesso
di cui tutti siamo
dati dell'empatia infatti oggi
conosciamo molto a livello scientifico
conosciamo la sua storia
nell'evoluzione della specie è stata
fondamentale per la cooperazione e per
la successione anche per la cura dei
piccoli e dei deboli
sappiamo anche molto dei circuiti
cerebrali associate allentati ha però
non basta pensare che l'empatia sia un
istinto o s'inneschi con una scarica di
neuroni
perché se fosse così non potremmo
spiegarci come mai la paura dell'altro è
un aspetto fondamentale non solo della
nostra società ma anche della nostra
vita paura qualche volta persino di
innamorarci perché abbiamo paura di
essere traditi di essere abbandonati
oltretutto poi pensiamo come sia
difficile oggi comunicare tra vecchi
giovani uomini e donne anche questa è
una storia purtroppo nefasta soprattutto
negli ultimi tempi tra ricchi e poveri
tra nord e sud tra gente che abita in
città è gente che abita in campagna il
mondo in cui noi viviamo
quindi fa dell'empatia quella che io
chiamo un wake up call cioè un
avvertimento anche che può essere anche
forte violento a investire le nostre
energie nel rischio nella difficoltà
molto spesso della scoperta dell'altro
l'empatia deve diventare per noi una
sveglia perché proprio in questo modo io
credo diventerà un turning point
fondamentale per il futuro di questo
mondo che attraversa crisi profonda
e non penso soltanto l'economia
ovviamente inter la finanza ma penso
anche all'ambiente
cioè solo in questo turning point che
per cui ognuno di noi mette qualcosa di
sé
incontrando l'altro facendo diciamo
affrontando l'esperienza delle relazioni
solo in questo modo forse fermeremo una
deriva catastrofica scoprire l'altro è
la quintessenza dell'empatia
poi sembrava una cosa piuttosto semplice
invece se pensiamo alla società digitale
ai mezzi di comunicazione al web ma
anche al mondo globalizzato scoprire
l'altro è non è così semplice in senso
che proprio i dispositivi digitali ma
anche i voli aerei che ci permettono
velocemente di andare da un'altra parte
del pianeta ci mettono contatto con
altri distanti di cui spesso non
conosciamo la lingua non conosciamo la
cultura non sappiamo niente delle sue
delle loro credenze o della loro fede
proprio perché queste nuove forme di
socialità in cui tutti siamo immersi ci
mettono contatto con altri senza nome
spesso gruppi popolazione appunto
vittime per esempio di catastrofi
naturali o di queste grandi migrazioni
d'altra parte altri che stanno con noi
abitano al mondo con noi sono parti
attore della nostra stessa scena proprio
per questo noi spesso ci fermiamo
simpatia e immediate oppure anche a
trattarli pulsione o avversioni
immediate faccio degli esempi che sono
note a tutti c'è perché noi ci
emozioniamo per la foto di un bimbo per
esempio quella famosa foto è diventata
virare al bambino tirato fuori dalle
macerie di aleppo e poi per esempio noi
italiani
quando andiamo benissimo d'accordo con
un immigrato che lavora in un mercato
oppure al bar
eppure nel piazzale della stazione
centrale
cirri ti amo perchè diciamo ma guardate
tutti questi presunti rifugiati che non
fanno niente tutto il giorno
questa è veramente una bella
contraddizione ma ci dice soprattutto la
fatica e la difficoltà di fare i conti
con la differenza dell'altro che sia un
giovane che sia un immigrato che sia un
anziano appunto che sia uno straniero
la prima lezione dell'empatia
da questo punto di vista sta proprio nel
prestare ascolto senza buttarci giù e
dire vabbè io sono egoista e quindi non
mi interesso
no dobbiamo prestare ascolto queste
nostre risposte spontanee a queste
nostre immediate avversione siamo anche
noi e come si dice
volgarmente abbiamo i nostri problemi ma
prestare ascolto e prenderle sul serio
vuol dire accettare che le nostre
attrazioni le nostre simpatie per le
nostre antipatie possono anche dare vita
a qualcosa di diverso e quindi possano
anche portarci a riconoscere il valore
di quelli che abitano il mondo insieme a
noi che come noi hanno delle emozioni
hanno dei pensieri hanno dei desideri la
scienza sta lavorando molto su questo
per esempio di questo secondo me è un
risultato interessante ci dice che non
esistono le persone naturalmente
empatiche un luogo comune che le donne
sono più fatica degli uomini
gli esperimenti neuroscienze hanno
abbastanza relativizzato questo tipo di
luogo comune che vuole anche dire che
esistono le persone gli uomini freddi
calcolatori egoisti geneticamente o
naturalmente anti empatici e tutto
questo cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
l'empatia è una capacità sicuramente
cablata nel cervello ma una capacità che
dobbiamo anche scegliere di coltivare e
quindi oltretutto poi sapendo che molto
delicata e molto fragile altri studi
altrettanto interessanti quelli che ho
appena citato
ci dicono che per esempio più facile
essere empatici con i nostri familiari
con chi appartiene al nostro gruppo al
nostro ambiente piuttosto che con quelli
che parlano un'altra lingua o di cui
conosciamo ben poco così pure si è si fa
più fatica e simpatici quando si è
stressati
oppure quando si e depressi cito in
questo tipo di conoscenza proprio per
dire come bisogna essere molto realisti
ma realisti anche nei confronti di noi
stessi cioè essere empatici non vuol
dire essere buoni e basta e quindi non
essere cattivi tutti noi viviamo a
seconda appunto delle circostanze di
vita delle fasi della vita se siamo più
giovani se siamo più adulti
se abbiamo altro tipo di problemi
viviamo dei momenti in cui l'empatia può
abbassarsi può essere anche un po
limitata un po scarsa ma tutto questo
non toglie che l'esperienza empatica
possa essere rinnovata e ripresa con
questo cosa voglio dire
in fondo la vita è una grande scuola di
empatia e vero che noi entriamo
in contatto con gli altri in maniera
estremamente entusiasmante nell'amore e
nell'amicizia e siamo coinvolti con le
nostre emozioni ma anche proprio con la
nostra sensibilità con le sensazioni
eppure ricordiamoci maul che basta
conversare con un amico con un'amica
uscendo da un cinema basta aprire la
finestra e guardare fuori guardare per
esempio un vecchietto un po malandato
che cammina a fatica perché le nostre
emozioni alle nostre sensazioni quindi
questa possibilità di aprirci alle
storie degli altri all'esistenza degli
altri anche solo per pochi secondi è una
possibilità alla portata di tutti in
questo senso dicevo la vita e scuole di
empatia viaggiare ci insegna a
empatizzare imparare le lingue straniere
per capire quelli che parlano una lingua
diversa dalla nostra
conversare piacere qualche volta anche
la noia della conversazione molto
importante proprio per vivere questa e
sviluppare questa formidabile capacità
umana che piena di potenzialità in un
mondo globale
in fondo noi dobbiamo reimparare ogni
giorno a stare insieme agli altri tre
uomini e donne tra genitori figli tra
studenti e insegnanti tra colleghi di
lavoro
ora questa diciamo ri apprendimento che
contrasta e vero con la velocità con ei
problemi delle nostre vite
quotidiane è però decisivo per rendere
il mondo più umano e per soprattutto
apprezzare l'umanità di quelli che
abitano la stessa la terra allo stesso
modo in cui la mettiamo noi con questo
vorrei lanciare il messaggio che
l'empatia ripeto una capacità di cui
tutti e tutte siamo dotati creativa e
generosa soprattutto ci porta a guardare
in avanti e questo è tanto più
importante in un mondo che ha paura oggi
del futuro greta no che bici vuoi adulti
ci rubate il futuro questa è un'accusa
pesantissima per noi adulti
l'empatia ci aiuta anche noi adulti non
solo i giovani a guardare in avanti a
rischiare ad accettare la fatica anche i
conflitti d'interesse anche di valori e
di forme di vita che sicuramente ci sono
quando entriamo in relazione con gli
altri perché in questo modo noi in fondo
arricchiamo la nostra vita e le nostre
esperienze e adesso concludo chiedendovi
una cosa ci fate solo un gesto
voltatevi verso il vostro vicino e
guardatelo dritto in faccia
poi fate un respiro profondo e come se
vi sentiste liberati da un peso
sorridente
[Applauso]
[Musica]